تذكر الوقت الذي قال فيه الرئيس ترامب
كيف سأبدو محظوظًا لأنني أبدو محظوظًا لأنني كلب على
لورد البيت الأبيض بهذا الحجم الكبير هنا
صغير زائف جيدًا هنا يسير
مع كلب خارج البيت الأبيض ،
الكلب البطل يطارد زعيم
إيزيس لذا هذا  هل كونان قد أعطينا كونان
للتو ميدالية ولوحة يمكنك سماعها تقريبًا وهو
يفكر في أنه قد تم إخباري بأنه سيكون هناك
طعام غير صحي كما تعلمون مثل كل هؤلاء
الرياضيين حتى أن مضيفي Fox News قاموا
بتحليل لغة الجسد التي كان مايك بنس
يستمتع بها مع ذلك الكونان اللذيذ
الرئيس بعيدًا قليلًا ،
كان الرئيس يرفع يده بينما
لم يستطع نائب الرئيس التوقف عن مداعبة
كونان وكونان ظل يتنشق ويتنشق
بنس.
عند تقديم تعليقات كونان ،
ما هذه الميدالية المزيفة المبتذلة التي
وضعها الرئيس على رقبتي ، إنها
تحتوي فقط على صورة لمخلب عليها
ما هو الجحيم أنك لا تمنح البشر
ميدالية مع foo  عندما ظهر كونان الحقيقي
، تم الترحيب به يا فتى
حسنًا ، في الواقع ، قيل لمراسل المسبح
أن كونان فتاة جيدة
ولكن بعد ذلك مسؤول في البيت الأبيض
عكس الجنس ولاحظ مراسل المسبح
كونان هو فتى طيب مرة أخرى
يلجأ أخيرًا  إن كونان كلبًا
جيدًا أدى إلى تعليقات مثل لم
ينظر أي شخص فقط إلى أنه ليس مثل الكلاب التي
ترتدي السراويل في اللحظة الأخيرة من
صاح المراسل ، لكن كونان لم يأخذ الأمر
شخصيًا ، هذا ملف تعريف ارتباط قاسي
لا تسميه بـ  أعطه ملف تعريف الارتباط واحدًا مما
يجعل هذا الذيل يهز أكثر جين موس
سي إن إن نيويورك